Ходити сходами 62-річній пенсіонерці Аллі Петрівніважко.
А дивитися в ці папірці взагалі лячно.
Квитанції за комунальні послуги жінка іронічно називає вироком.
Майже судовим.
Сума боргу, який накопичився за 2 роки -8 тисячгривень за гарячу воду
і7 тисячгривень за опалення.
Алла Петрівна розуміє, що з такими боргами їй не дадуть субсидію.
А без субсидії на її пенсією не прожити.
Пенсія в мене1435гривень. Як виходити з цієї ситуації, я не знаю.
Я сплачую якимось частинками, але погасити неможливо.
І це тільки одна квитанція.
1435 гривень - мінімальна пенсія.
Так оцінила держава її 39 років роботи спочатку в Національному університеті
на філологічному факультеті, а потім заступницею головного редактора однієї з київських газет.
Алла Петрівна не може претендувати навіть на середню пенсію в2 500гривень.
Адже пенсія розраховується відповідно до офіційних відомостей роботодавців,
які за хибною практикою по всій країні через бухгалтерію проводили мінімальні суми зарплат,
аби платити менше податків.
Ітака ситуація у багатьох з 12 мільйонів пенсіонерів України.
У мене 43 роки стажу.
Сказали, що була мала зарплата і малий коефіцієнт. Тому і така пенсія.
Ці жінки не можуть розраховувати на велику допомогу від своїх синів,
бо їм самим не вистачає на життя.
Допомагає, звичайно, коли може. Ми разом живемо.Але якби не він, то й здохла б.
Порахувати на що вистачить1435гривень пенсії не складно.
У випадку Алли Петрівни цього вистачить максимум на ліки.
Або вона буде терпіти підвищений тиск, біль у ногахі придбає більше продуктів, але геть не всіх.
Це я одразу проходжу повз. Ціни нереальні. Постоїш, як кажуть, понюхаєш і йдеш далі.
Українське сало теж не завжди входить у продуктовий кошик українських пенсіонерів.
І справжній український борщ, схоже, що теж.
Борщ треба з м’ясом варити.
Останнім часом я зрідка роблю його на курячих спинках.
Але це ж не той борщ.
Сьогодні Алла Петрівна може купити дві морквинки і три яблука на 13 гривень. Це її солодощі.
Не на один день. Це на три.
Так і живемо.
7 років тому, коли Алла Петрівна вийшла на пенсію, їй призначили близько 900 гривень.
Тоді це було приблизно 100 доларів.
Зараз у гривневому еквіваленті сума наче б то збільшилася,
алев доларовому, навпаки, зменшилася вдвічі.
Наразі триває друга на її пам’яті пенсійна реформа,
що передбачає поступове підвищення пенсій. Зокрема, з 1 грудня.
Ось підвищили в грудні на 80 гривень.
Ось я хочу спитати у тих, хто втілював цю реформу в життя.
Можна на ці 80 і мізерну пенсію прожити?
Вони піднімають на копійки, а витрати зростають на сотні.
Аби вижити в Києві, пересічному пенсіонеру потрібно не менше5 тисяч гривень.
Це Алла Петрівна вирахувала зі своєю подругою.
Та додає: це якщо ти більш-менш здоровийі готовий ходити в одязі, що купив до пенсії.
Ось, люди добрі.Я ношу чоботи, курточку, яку я купила 7 чи 8 років назад.
На пенсію ми нічого не можемо
Сидимо у боргах від пенсії до пенсії.
Перепозичаємо.
Подруги іронічно називають себе "жіночим пенсійним батальйоном,
який бореться за виживання в умовах соціальної несправедливості".
Тож, попри усі свої хвороби  намагаються десь підзаробити.
Алла Петрівна пішла працювати в службу соцзахисту,
доглядає за ще більш літніми людьми, як ця бабуся, якій вже 86.
Ця робота дає їй додаткові3 тисячігривень щомісяця.
Захист від депресивних думок колишня редакторка знаходить у мріях.
Все своє життя я мріяла потрапити вЛувр. Це в мене як нав’язлива ідея.
Я, буває, навіть сплю і мені це сниться…
Або ж в улюбленому своєму занятті - читанні.
Як оптимістка, вона вірить в те, що рано чи пізно до влади прийдуть політики,
які з більшою увагою ставитимуться до пенсіонерів,
і вона зможе на свою пенсію не лише дивитися на продукти і проходити повз, а й купувати їх.